our continuing series a more perfect
union aims to show that what unites us
as Americans is stronger than what
divides us this morning we look at two
young NFL players who only recently met
they're taking part in a program
designed to help them find work after
their playing days are over that means a
different kind of training camp this one
is on Capitol Hill Nancy Cordes is there
with how they're tackling public service
Nancy good morning good morning well 41
NFL players John are taking part in this
program giving up part of their
offseason to work in what they're
calling externships they're working at
places like the United Way and Under
Armour and a couple of them have come
here to Congress to tackle the partisan
divide like many offensive lineman these
two start their day at the gym pole
toner plays for the LA Chargers Brian
Whitman for the Kansas City Chiefs but
from there they hit Capitol Hill
swapping out their jerseys for suits
answer calls we send out emails to the
constituents that's a big switch from
your usual job right all right it's
traded one playbook for the intern
playbook wits Minh works for Illinois
congresswoman Robin Kelly a Democrat
coach how's he been doing he's been
doing great we don't want him to leave
really like we have a superstar in
office toner was assigned to Republican
senator Todd young of Indiana he'd run
running right away and I've also been
writing some some decision memos for him
which is fantastic yeah how are they
they're legible they're thoughtful
they're types of they should be and
persuasive at six seven and six five the
two are hard to miss what made you want
to come to Capitol Hill but I've always
had kind of had some interest in public
policy and fiscal policy and econ and
that kind of stuff so I think it might
be something I get into someday
I think he's he has so many other
options cold lows but he chose to come
here and I hope it inspires others
whit's Minh played for South Dakota
State University before going pro toner
is a Harvard grad from Indiana they had
never met but now they're roommates and
friends whose political views diverge
hang out every night I go eat dinner
play some video games do what teammates
do so I mean I don't really think of him
as across the aisle he's convicted as
accused but uh he's very reasonable very
uh when we debate on things it's always
about improving our our knowledge on
stuff they take the same view on the
decision by some of their colleagues to
kneel during the national anthem in
protest of what some saw as unfair
treatment of african-americans at the
hands of police President Trump and some
fans called it disrespectful wouldn't
you love to see one of these NFL owners
when somebody disrespects our flag to
say get that son of a [ __ ] off the
field right now he's fired
neither tonin or wits Minh took a knee
but say they respect those who did I
think it was for the most part guys are
very supportive of one another and I
think most guys have had my opinion too
that you can if you wanted to do that
it's within your rights or it's like
public figures and they're having like a
deep interview they've both found DC
isn't as divided as it seems there are
tons of bills and resolutions every day
that I've actually been researching that
have a lot of bipartisan support I
wouldn't think of a Republican or
Democrat being on the other side as an
opponent I almost think of it as you're
on the same team ultimately at the end
of the day they have to come together
for the team to progress and for it to
win they're externships and today and
while they've learned a lot they've
taught a little to get any advice for me
you never skip leg day when you workout
you can't go into the gym with huge arms
oh I've been doing it all wrong small
legs you know yeah
great advice for all of us the average
NFL career only lasts three years
believe it or not and that's a big part
of the reason that the Players
Association started this externship
program five years ago Alex
and indeed you need to be an offensive
tackle to get anything done in power I
think that they're doing that though
it's great boys I like it
Jefferson said that to never skip leg
day
[Music]